this is a production of Cornell
University
thank you Louis for that kind
introduction
um pleasure to be here it took me many
decades to get here I've been wanting to
come to Cornell one time when we were
touring the colleges and universities in
2019 uh for my son
um we we were scheduled to come to
Cornell and we were stuck in Newark
Airport for 36 hours okay so we came
close but not quite so it's good to be
here physically although I I see
familiar faces here and I'm glad I'm on
the campus and and good to see you all
thank you for coming
this afternoon here I think the room is
quite full so that's that's nice always
I still see people keep coming into the
room that must be the food right
and that's a good sign when people are
coming in this direction I have given a
lot of talks and there have been times
when people are getting up and and going
out and I was I was in a one talk like
that I was sitting up front and the
person who was giving the talk and
people were leaving and leaving and
leaving and then I happened to be the
last person sitting up front so I said
Dwayne uh no the person who was speaking
said Raj are you really interested in
what I had to say and I said no not
really I'm the next speaker
so um I'm going to talk about Precision
agriculture that has been my bread and
butter my uh
uh my uh Courier for the last 30 years a
lot of work has happened with graduate
students like Louis longchamps who spend
seven plus years in my lab first as grad
student then as a postdoc
and um it has been a really interesting
Journey so uh it's a little bit of
looking back and and then bringing you
up to speed where things are today and
what we're doing
um in in Precision AG in our lab so let
me start with the question I always like
to start with a question
what is this picture
I can give you a hint uh each one of you
use it every day
foreign
so this is the first uh GPS unit that
was developed by Rockwell Collins In
1976 Louis mentioned I served two terms
on NASA board when I saw this uh picture
first time it was very intriguing
and in a matter of
less than 20 years it went from a size
of this GPS unit which will fit only
maybe half a dozen in this room
to something that you can hold it on the
tip of your finger that's the chip
that's in every cell phone if you have a
cell phone that you bought after year
2000 you have that chip okay and so it's
kind of hard to imagine how agriculture
or Society or technology will change in
the next 20 years okay because that
happened it surprised even scientist at
Nasa how dramatically we change you can
hold it on the tip of your finger it's
in every cell phone okay now the initial
mobile unit that was given for military
purposes I don't know how many of you
have Googled this picture it looks
something like this
okay
and this is me in late 90s mapping
nitrogen stress in corn fields in
Colorado
okay so before Kansas State I was in
Colorado State for 20 some years uh
where I had my entire uh faculty career
I'm wearing a welcome velcro tape here
with a Data Logger that's connected
through artists 232 port to Minolta spad
meter I have a two kilo monochromatic
Fujitsu and tablet with a revolving hard
disk not a solid state and of course I'm
carrying bunch of deep cycle batteries
to power the Trimble unit it used to be
heavy and the more you walked it got
heavier okay but that's how we were
mapping nitrogen stress at that that
time and that would be the common theme
you will see in my talk today
ability to quantify
variability in crop and salt parameters
that's what my entire career has been
about and then creating decisions to
make those management okay
so now I now take you to 1983 what
happened in 83.
absolutely right the GPS became
accessible for civilian purposes okay
and so if you took my Precision act
course I taught three courses at
Colorado State one of the first
Laboratories we will do is take multiple
different GPS units that work on
different frequencies go to a benchmark
and we'll do an error analysis okay so
you do the northing and the easting and
then you calculate the circular error
probable meaning where does the 50 of
the data reside in XY domain and lo and
behold back then it you know you're
lucky if you're within the 50 meters
plus minus 50 meters and I pulled a
paper from IEEE and lo and behold the
horizontal positioning for standard
signal which is SPS used to be 100
meters and what military had without
correction which is precise positioning
system used to be 20 meters okay so we
have come a long ways and if you look at
the pub Publications that were coming
out during those days were focused on
hey we got access to GPS and this is how
we can improve the signaling and make it
more precise and differential
and I don't know if you guys can read
the authors here I want to draw your
attention to one individual Brad
Parkinson
who is he
a lot of people don't know about this
Brad Parkinson is the father of GPS
global Positioning Systems okay a
professor and Stanford and that's where
him and his colleagues for a thumb uh
they are the brains behind the GPS in
fact just before covet Queen Elizabeth
awarded them with a million pounds award
for being instrumental in engineering
okay all four were four were
on that and I got to know Dr Parkinson
quite well I was uh privileged to be he
he's the co-chair still today he's the
co-chair of NASA board U.S presidential
Advisory board on positioning navigation
and training this is one of our meetings
in Washington DC that's him and some of
you may know uh Dr James Ginger he was
the first Secretary of of uh energy and
then he had multiple other assignments
and um
so I look a little bit younger I'm still
young right
um I want to draw your attention to the
person who's sitting right next to me uh
late Dr Ronald hatch
so today decimeter accuracy in uh
tractor systems or combine systems are
so common
he's the brains behind that so he was
the brains behind the Starfire that John
Deere inherited and be able to provide
decimeter accuracy without any
Correctional signals because they got
access to not the encrypted data but the
frequency on Dual frequencies and GPS so
um so a lot of contribution there and um
while the literature was focused more on
hey how could we improve accuracy of GPS
in those days there was this individual
whose Wheels were turning
that hey we now have access to this is
Dr late Dr Pierre Robert who was
designated as the father of precision
agriculture a Belgian scientists
established the first Precision act
Center in the University of Minnesota a
good friend and colleague he passed away
untimely he was thinking as as a
Visionary as he was that how one day
location-based agriculture may become a
reality and so after one of these
tri-society meetings ASA cssa and SSA
these colleagues are sitting in a bar in
Chicago you know with their beer in
their hand and they start scribbling on
a piece of napkin here I reconstructed
it by by the way it's not the real
napkin I don't hold that with me uh that
that one day that we will embracing GPS
as a mundane Affair and and so ipni
which is no longer longer their
international plan nutrition Institute
closed down after 75 years took this to
their designers and this was put
together
so this this was at one point of time
and Harold may remember that this was
one of the most widely used infogram or
what Precision agriculture may become
one day it came out in I think in 84 or
85 something like that but one thing
that that the founders of precision act
cautioned us
that once we are uh you know engaged in
location-based agriculture
that'll give rise to lots and lots and
lots of data
and I think that's where we are today
that's exactly where we are today and so
I'll be talking a lot about engagement
with data and data analytics as we
continue to solve the challenge of
spatial temporal management looking into
the future okay
variability happens right I was flying
in yesterday I saw a tremendous amount
of variability in landscape and
topography and soil and soil type crop
cover uh stuff like that this is a
picture taken from a um from an airplane
looking down it could be anywhere in
Colorado Western Kansas parts of
Nebraska and so forth and so the fields
are not alike so this is landscape scale
variability I can zoom in on a farm that
may have 20 30 pivots and other
grain-fed Agriculture and they still
don't look alike so that's a farm scale
variability I can zoom in on one field
where we have done some work and you
still see variability in soil and and
that inherent variability is what we
have been trying in my lab along with
several others were after quantifying
without having to actually acquire a lot
of soil samples how could we do it in
economic atomically affordable manner
less labor-intensive manner this is
where the remote sensing came in
okay and so it has an implication
because
oftentimes not always but oftentimes
this inherent variability I'm going to
click next and show you the crops
growing on these fields translates into
that crop although the entire field is
treated uniformly that inherent
variability if I were to go here it
translates into the crop production
system okay so if you're putting 150
pounds of nitrogen across the entire
field you know it's not in your corn not
across the entire field and that was the
whole point there's a holy grail of
precision agriculture how do we make
Taylor
Management Systems to feed the entire
field and it has been 30 years since our
capability to quantify grain yield you
know it's a pixel by pixel combine is
moving on the motion you can we can pick
but
unfortunately even today how are farmers
managing their fields
and so I'm gonna I you know
um our lab did this quick analysis many
many years back so here's your combine
and he's just a schematic here so it's
moving and it's harvesting depending on
the size of the header six row 12 row
whatever number of rows and every second
is dropping a pixel quantifying how much
granial is coming from there you Stitch
the whole thing together it becomes a
digital yield map so quantifying how
much you're harvesting from each and
every part of the field you go through
the cleaning process because they're
errors associated with that uh once you
have cleaned the data if you were to run
quick statistics it'll give you the uh
you know frequency distribution here and
in this particular example average is
180 bushel to an acre okay this example
is more than 20 years old
so
here's simple query that you can write
in any of the platforms that you're
working on so how many pixels match the
average
date louder
less than 20 any other guesses
zero okay is there some pessimists in
the room exactly
yes it's a mathematical average it
doesn't in this example two percent okay
and I remember one of my colleagues at
the keynote in info AG many years back
and said well if you are chasing average
you're missing the target 100 of the
time and I said you exaggerated it's 98
of the time
so well that's and when we showed this
data exactly like what you said it's the
mathematical mean it doesn't exist
anywhere so to satisfy Farmers curiosity
we said okay how about we go plus and
minus one percent of the mean that may
be more realistic what do you think
happens now
okay
or ten percent yeah you know 10 12
depends on the field and so forth in
fact to to further illustrate our point
we went plus minus five percent and now
you're talking about 10 bushels on each
side is still what happens is 40 percent
so you know if you're chasing average it
doesn't exist it doesn't exist it's when
was the last time that you had normal
weather
foreign
so even with that plus minus 10 bushel
on each side even if you were to call
that large window as average
20 of the field one-fifth of the field
you over fertilized in this example and
35 percent of the field you did not
apply enough
okay that's an over simplistic version
there are soil fertility soil scientists
including myself in the room they will
disagree but this is just an example to
give you a point when you are chasing
average you're missing the Target and so
this has been the key mantra for
precision AG how do we manage
variability well you can only manage
what you can measure so the key question
is how do you measure variability and
once you measure it then how do you
manage variability and so that's that
has been a lot of work in my in my lab
along with several other
um around the nation and the world this
is one of the fields that we did a lot
of grit soil sampling so we went out
with a coarser grid this work one work
was done in 97 98 99 I'm kind of dating
myself this is bear with me this this
led to development of a lot of signs so
in one field those three years we went
out and did a coarser uh sampling
and then in one part of the field we
said well
um let's do a finer grade sampling so we
went out and sampled very intensively
and the final were saying you're taking
all the top soil away to your lab you
know
we did so much sampling there and just
like any Precision practitioner you
first want to estimate the spatial range
or the distance at which there's a
correlation versus no correlation it
turns out that for this sampling the
spatial range happens to be 15 meters
okay and that will require 2500 soil
samples
to accurately capture this is nitrogen a
lot of our work is with nitrogen to
accurately capture distribution of
nitrogen in the surface soil that
require 2500 salt samples now how many
of you students will sign up for that
let alone Farmers or practitioners it's
it's unteenable and the Nugget effect is
so bad that for all the sampling we did
here
amounted to nothing
you cannot interpolate now there are a
lot of softwares out there you click
click click we'll crop create the
surface that has no technical Merit
okay and so there was a book that our
good colleague and friend Margaret
Oliver and Ruth Carey edited I have a
chapter in there and in the very opening
chapter Margaret says well for you to do
accurate prediction you not only have to
measure variability at the spatial range
you have to do that at half the spatial
range
so that's an exponential function if you
pull out your calculator it's a 55
hectare field you do the math now we're
talking about seven meter by seven meter
how many salt samples now
exactly it's an exponential function
it's ten thousand soil samples before
you do that so we learned it really
quickly that look it's labor intensive
time consuming and not economically
affordable we need an alternate we need
an alternate that can accurately
quantify variability without without
those parameters so and yet throughout
my journey in my Precision act world uh
we want something that's diagnostic so
grit fall sampling is diagnostic okay
but it's destructive
okay and time consuming labor-intensive
cost prohibitive and must be deployed at
spatially dependent scales if you want
to have meaningful outcomes okay so it
become it became very very hard and
that's exactly what led to us writing
the proposal in 1999 that was funded
partly by NASA and and USDA there used
to be an initiative called ifas so my
lab was one of them that got that
funding for a million dollars which used
to be a lot at that time still is today
and so four of my PhD students worked on
developing four different techniques of
management zones
so they um
they worked on looking at so many
different ways how do we capture
variability employing remote sensing
virtual imagery topography Farmers
experience at in those days we didn't
have access to 10 years of yield map uh
and and so and this became a commercial
product there's a company called
Centennial AG that was the first one
that embraced it and then iterations of
this was picked up everywhere in the
union and north of the border Canada
uses it and so many other places as a as
our work has taken
so uh we need a data collection at high
spatial densities that has been our
question and how do we address that so
fast forward this is 2012. I
had a quarter of a quarter section okay
so quarter section is 160 Acres so we
have a quarter of a quarter section that
was forwardgated I got some money from
my endowment and I said I'm going to put
in a Precision pivot systems okay so
this still exists and this is one of our
site where we continue to do Works uh
work and so the system that we built
here is the Precision Irrigation System
one of the very first ones at that time
in the country
that has drop nozzles five feet apart
and you can change the rate of
application of water at every nozzle
level
okay so mathematically speaking you have
five thousand plus management pixels
right and here's the drop nozzle that
you can change the rate of application
at every nozzle level and you can
actuate that at every two degrees of
pivot movement you do the quick map and
so that's 5400 mathematical Water
Management zones and this is where I
have said in my papers as well the
technology is ahead of science this is
the technology I'm working with where is
my decision map
and we're still working on this today
where's my decision map does it even
make sense to be applying differential
rates of water just because I have
technology right okay and then there are
so many unknowns we does it even make
sense to apply differential rate I just
said that how do we figure out how much
water to be applied in each zone or in
each pixel how many zones are ideal uh
do these Zone chains do they change
every season or every time you actuate
your pivot or lateral okay how often
does that change how much does it change
and how often
and how do I measure if I have the tool
to manage
my management pixel is five feet by five
feet roughly right it's a quadrilateral
it's not a square
and so how do I measure so that Quest
before it was only for nitrogen then we
started to be dabbling with water water
and nitrogen go together I've always
worked at irrigated systems okay and so
we said how do we measure that
you'll go back to the drawing board you
go out send your students out to measure
with TDR soil moisture on the surface
soil calculate that this is their
spatial dependence and based on that
this field this is a 22 acre pivot
needed 84
sensing nodes
so I wrote a proposal to John Deere John
Deere was in used to be in water systems
at that time I see I said I need 100
sensing nodes
in my system they said you guys are
crazy you said well we know it but we
still need to do it
okay because I need to be able to
quantify so this is wireless sensor node
uh John Deere gave us about 10 or 12
such systems we later have partnership
with heartau and they gave us some more
systems we couldn't do this work and
imagine 10 foot tall pole in these many
locations in the field farmer is going
to love you right
this is not the way to go and each
sensor node is about three to five
thousand dollars in 2012.
okay we we did this work on one half of
the field okay and bless his heart uh uh
dongwei he was a visiting scholar
postdoc in my lab and he was looking for
a project he got excited I can do this
so he went out with access to to measure
soil moisture every week sometimes twice
a week
to quantify how much was in the profile
at five death and Louis LED this work uh
we we established spatial and temporal
variability and there were some key
messaging this was so good for the
irrigation company
that there has to be dynamic Water
Management Zone each time
you actuate your pivot okay in fact the
Zone could change because pivot may take
two and a half three or five days to go
around the entire field okay so the
challenge was how do we measure soil
moisture in situ non-destructively at
spatial dependent skills and why just
water why not other parameters as well
and lo and behold five years back John
Deere came out with this spray CN spray
that you can act to it any nozzle so now
again your management is like two feet
by two feet
and how many senses would it take to
measure and we're talking diagnostic
measurement not surrogate measure like
remote sensing or sensor based
and so this challenge has been uh
something that we have been trying to
address okay we want high spatial
density diagnostic rapid and expensive
in fact that became part of the chapter
uh that I co-authored at the National
Academy of Sciences science
breakthroughs 2030 report that was
presented to Congress in 2018.
and um we said okay could we try that
with sensors so I'm going to show you
some of the work that Louis did while he
was in my lab we said how about we go to
the sensor route okay look at
inexpensive sensors can we do that right
it's diagnostic high spatial density and
so forth so there's a company out of
France reached out to us this used to be
a forty thousand dollar sensor they said
well we'll present it to you for you
know for for nitrogen purposes at that
time they were only selling this to
Vineyards to measure the phenolic
component of the grapes for high quality
wines we said okay let's give it a try
and and we came up with the idea how
about we measure Optical properties
using fluorescence in soil
I said well does it even make sense so
he did some literature review on lo and
behold there was literature to back it
up so that's exactly what what he did so
it's a multiplex fluorescent sensor
there are four induction channels
ultraviolet and RGB and there are three
detection channels so your output is 12
different parameters
and of course you can create your own
ratios to come up even more
it's actuated at 400 Hertz
and so in every second of your work it
generates a lot of data points you use
it for one second it's just both loads
of data okay the longer you work with it
it's just you're collecting data data
and more data okay and so uh he went out
to the field came up with a randomized
sampling design this is Louis working
with the Prototype newer version a lot
lighter newer version uh and it was in a
bucket he he's very good at fixing
things together and he walked the entire
field that's what he did okay
and so that's a closer shot uh how he
was doing that and so he walked
everywhere and was collecting uh for
several seconds what else we did we we
took soil samples from there so he took
it out in the field and then we dried it
created a uniform pattern and then had
our student help us out with that we did
this work for for uh three years there
were nine sites that's Tawny after
drying it she's working in the lab ready
to shine or fluoresce the soil and and
take measurements there in the
laboratory so this these are our samples
visually speaking I I can't see a whole
lot of difference other than color
and this is this data sat with us for a
long time because it was hard to figure
out what can we do
we recently hired a postdoc who has
machine learning and artificial
intelligence competencies and he was
looking at the data and so I'm going to
draw an analogy here
um
and so how do we deploy machine learning
I've had a big extension appointment so
I tried to break it down here so we said
okay how do Google uh you know or these
cameras work right what do they do
they're training the cameras all the
time you're taking so many pictures so
I'm going to pick up one of the global
celebrities how about Bill Gates okay so
everybody can can recognize Bill Gates
so here's Mr gaze with the same uh you
know glasses and similar looking uh
sweater and you tell the computer hey
that's Bill Gates okay that's Bill Gates
that's Bill Gates but here he changes
his his orientation and the sweater
changes you tell the computer hey this
is also Bill Gates right and he may lose
the sweater okay he may look different
right so what we're trying to do we're
trying to train the computer and that's
one of the fallacies we have that we
need lots and lots of data to first
train the computer and that doesn't
exist in agriculture right now how many
iterations do I have for the pivot for
me to train the machine so that it can
go into the predictability so what
happens he loses the sweater his
orientation changes and you're mixing it
with different ages of Mr Bill Gates can
the computer still recognize it it makes
mistakes you know Google makes lots of
mistakes you know that right and it gets
more and more complex he's getting
younger the you know the pattern behind
changes he loses the sweater as well as
the jacket what happens now what it
recognize what happens if it gets very
younger
right can it it's still accurately
identify and then if you do enough
learning
can it now predict how it's going to
look next
and that's exactly what we're trying to
chase that if I train the pivot and the
sensors enough so that the sensor can
look the information ahead of the pivot
feed that information on the edge
computer and send the decision mag back
to the pivot so I can apply the right
amount of water at the right place at
the right time right our our USD a goal
by 2050 is to cut down our water
footprint by 50 percent
I'm in Kansas sitting on Ogallala
last year alone it depleted two feet the
report came out last week it depleted
two feet
so it's not going to stay there forever
last year was a very dry year
okay so how do we do that and what
happens here
who is this
thank you so there is no no substitute
for human intelligence this is Steve
Jobs it turns out Mr Gates used to look
like him too back then
laughs
and what happens if I look at the
comparison
it requires a lot of training now this
is only the visual element right the
difference is only visual element that
I'm trying to make it very easy here
okay and it gets very complex and what
happens here I mean those two are very
different looking individuals so will
the machine perform what we're training
it to do and about soil soils are simple
right
It's mighty challenging trying to train
the signals coming from soil not just
physical property but also chemical
property uh to see okay what can we
learn from those iterations so here's
the data set he averaged it uh this is
the bunker he averaged the data and so
now you have that many predictions so 12
channels plus some more modified indices
and then you are basically running uh
mapping in multi-dimension right that's
what you're trying to do
okay and um you start looking at what
are significant relationship we picked
up three or four of those based on that
he parceled 70 of the data to train the
model okay and then he used 30 of the
data to test the model
so training R is 0.91 R is 0.57 one of
the things we realized that the fields
where we were doing sampling had very
low nitrogen parts per million and so we
did a better job with low and the model
really stinks as you get into higher
parts per million okay so again it based
on what we are training the model to
perform right
um
so
um what can we do next
if one day we're successful and there
are many Laboratories that are trying to
resolve this challenge okay if we're
successful we can have an unknown soil
sample use some kind of Technology you
know I'm not endorsing any and then you
do go through the optimum feature
selection have a train a model then the
regression you have a soil estimate and
you go to the end recommendation I want
to caution you it requires huge amount
of data for the training purposes your
results is only going to be as good as
what you can train it but you can
collect data in high spatial density uh
it used to be 40 Grand I think it's now
down to 19 000. okay so the more such
and there have been improvements in
inversion uh diagnostic no this is also
a surrogate measure rapid
a person has to go out I mean you can
mount it on a on a machine uh but uh
this unit right now
fails miserably in motion
okay so person has to walk over their
actuate fluorescence and then move on
inexpensive no
uh data processing and Analysis this
requires high amount of skill labor okay
so this has been our Quest that how do
we get spatial high density rapid and
inexpensive and so uh this is again
Louis and Rafael out in the field
sampling our our best technology that's
affordable uh is out there make a soil
solution and do a nitrate nitrate test
check
okay it's more qualitative and
quantitative or there's a lock one meter
that gives you uh you know in parts per
million okay
so that's that's what it is right
now talking with Engineers uh they say
hey we can measure this and so you have
a reference electrode and a working
electrode and you have got a power
circuit and reader if we can identify a
working electrode that can measure
nitrates and soil solution you dip it
and you test it out against different
molar Solutions and the response to
voltage is fairly good and as you change
the molarity of the you know nitrate
sodium nitrate
it gives you a stair step so that's an
aha moment can we translate that into a
very inexpensive nitrate sensor that can
measure nitrogen distribution in soil
and high spatial densities diagnostic
rapid and expensive uh destructive
involves labor time consuming if you
have to go out and do it yourself and
that's exactly what I was referring to
the science breakthroughs report that I
was part of part of at National
Academies
and if you read the chapter
it mentions that this ought to happen if
we want to go to the next level of
precision management it says it out
right there
and for us to become competitive in The
Proposal world we added three more
things when we wrote this proposal to
arpa e we said our sensor will be
battery less
it will be passive and we'll build it on
a biodegradable material
we didn't know what we were signing up
for we got the you know we got the Grant
and I was making this presentation at
the Western Governors uh Forum annual
Forum in Las Vegas and I was making a
point that I need sensors and I can
literally distribute it out in the field
that are inexpensive and so forth and
then I ran into an engineers and we can
do this you know what we can actually
print the sensors for you
we are doing this in our in our lab I
said really
and so said okay so that became the Holy
Grail then last four years we have been
working my lab with UC Boulder material
scientists at UC Berkeley Computer
Engineering and beer scientists to
develop biodegradable printed sensors
and you literally print it on a screen
print okay and so you have um you have a
reference electrode you have insulating
layer of course this is how once you
have the screen made that's how you
print it on a conductive ink I gave this
very detailed presentation at the last
American society Agronomy meetings and
you you can literally print it and then
once you have the electrodes that
matches up you can dip it into the
solution to start measuring okay the
first prototype is eight of these
sensors are in the greenhouse testing
going on right now uh we have been
developing nitrate as well as soil
moisture sensor that that are being
printed okay and I'll uh so this is you
know version zero right and of course
we're using a circuit board because
we're far away from degree degradable
sensor so if you're successful our idea
is that we'll have a degradable material
okay that will print the circuit and the
electrode directly on it it can be done
conceptually it can be done it proves
okay the sensor works fine for two or
three days in lab conditions
okay but it fails miserably it has been
lasting right now we are Beyond two
weeks it's working okay
okay the nitrate is is really finicky
okay so it has some of those properties
reliable I will not go that far
okay it's it drifts uh inexpensive
battery less passive also
um we are we're decoupling the
biodegradable element if we can just get
a nitrate sensor that works that are
inexpensive you can print it I think
that will be a win and accuracy and
precision are are again there's so many
Hoops that we have to jump
um that that we're not there yet we went
through a lot of material testing where
we did accelerated degradation we'll put
in harsh environment put it on the
Shaker for 24 hours that I don't know
what the sensors will experience in the
soil what happens if the plow goes right
through or before detail goes right
through what happens to the sensor we
did that we also continuously are doing
uh fuel studies in the greenhouse with
different materials when you use
different soil types sand versus peat
versus uh clay the performance and the
drifting of the sensor happens big time
there are lots of oops to be jumped you
can imagine and then we keep taking
destructive samples to see at different
time frames at how the sensors or the
sensor materials are behaving they don't
behave so well now we do want these
sensors to fail at some point of time
but our time Target is 200 days so you
distribute these sensors out in the
field you don't have to go back and
collect them okay and then they break
down and they go you can tell we won't
get rich selling these sensors because
our Target price is like you know a few
pennies
okay you can just print them print them
print them right but the money is not in
the sensor the money is in the data
because you know farmer won't invest I
could imagine practitioners go out and
embed the field with sensor technology
and then you're collecting data in X and
Y and Z depth and time T so you're
working with multi-dimensional data set
it'll require a lot of machine learning
and AI algorithms for us to get to the
decision map we have been publishing all
along uh in in some good journals what
we are we are learning
we did a lot of dummy sensor field
testing uh with different because it has
to be encapsulated so that the sensor
don't degrade before we want it a lot of
a lot of grunt work is has been going on
uh lots of successes tremendous amount
of failures I can tell you right now uh
this is not easy and how the sensor same
sensor behaves in different soil types
we're very cognizant of that we're not
close to where we could be moisture
sensor from our learning we're uh we're
a little bit closer than uh we are for
the nitrate sensors you start with the
biodegradable material you etch it with
this stencil then you fill it with the
conductive ink you etch the conductive
ink again so that it can conduct
whatever signal we're trying to do and
it becomes conductive and that's where
we add a couple of wires so that now we
can communicate with that and then you
encapsulate that with a vax coding if
the video still works it's a good one
this one of my co-pis
this is the balsa wood substrate right
we print on right so we put a stencil on
top right the shape of the the electrode
pattern right right and then we we use
just a blade to coat through this
stencil pattern and the ink is right
here we use an ink like this yeah
exactly uses zinc ink and when you do
that and when we do that we get a we get
a uh we get a electrode pattern that
prints on the balsa wood that looks like
that made of the zinc correct but it's
not conductive because we have to make
it conductive so we dip it into a
solution of acetic acid correct which
etches the zinc oxide layer correct
makes it conductive then we attach wires
um
to be able to communicate with it to
interact with it we use a you know like
an epoxy to do that we connect the wires
and you use this mold and then we use a
mold and in the mold though we then coat
the wax we have to be very careful like
a lot of the trick in this is coating
the wax and making sure there's no
cracks like you can see it's a very good
wax code correct um and so that's string
and that is basically a complete sensor
right go closer I will see the
communication wires yeah so we can
connect these obviously to electronics
and then ultimately in the future we'll
just connect them to a RFID so the first
prototype may look something like this
is missing the board right now missing
the electronics board which will go
there so these there'll be an
Electronics board here which will do
Wi-Fi communication okay these two wires
will connect to that board and then this
will go in the soil right up to about
there to make measurements right and um
that'll be what our first and we can
program it such that it can record at
any frequency we choose yes yeah within
reason yeah okay excellent thank you
so it doesn't have any battery okay we
we use a radio frequency wave the sensor
is sleeping all the time we wake it up
for a millisecond it does the work soil
solution around it measures it sends the
signal and we record it and as many
times as we actuate it it provides sorry
also would Subs right right
um are our vice president of research
office did a cover story on the work
that we're doing there I don't know how
they took this picture but it's a pretty
good looking picture of of this this is
just a starting point for uh sensor node
setup that we have we always measure it
with commercial sensor to see how well
the commercial sensor is performing
against our sensor Network you always
grow plant on it just want to make sure
when you do these kind of things
commercial vendors reach out to you say
hey we have figured this out by the way
would you like to test do that so we
created a test bed there's a company out
of Finland
that reached out to us apparently they
have been following our work for the
last 20 years and
um they said well we will give you those
sensors these are battery powered
sensors they're very small but the
battery will last 20 years because the
sensor is sleeping all the time it's
non-degratable and stuff so we did
create a test bed at the North Farm this
is this is the and we had to go through
a bunch of Hoops in order for the them
to be uh pinged and data to be read so
here's the base station solar powered
Wi-Fi module in these rows are where we
had 24 sensors in a in a field size of
like this room that that was our test
bed uh that we did last year and so we
actuated from our lab as and you can
program it for frequency and then my
postdoc wrote a a app that you can
immediately can create a surface map or
a heat map that as he calls it so this
is a two-dimensional heat map and we did
this at two depths
okay so as many times as you actuate
data and X Y and Z you can
oops so you can have this that this is
only for the surface for multiple times
what happens with depth I don't know how
to what weight should I give to uh six
inches depth versus 24 inches depth
versus 36 inches depth
we don't know right now so there's a lot
of unknowns this is this work that we
have been doing for the last 10 15 years
we go out and measure electrical
conductivity so what my lab has been
doing is till we don't have the sensors
we don't need to wait to work with
spatial temporal data set so in any
given year we collect 30 some data
layers and I'm just stacking it up right
here to create that big data set
and
foreign
machine learning
employ some of the AI algorithms uh you
know these are self-explanatory that
what kind of data layers that you can
collect all the way down to the yield
map
um
and then help translate into your
decision I don't even know what the
relevance is or weight Matrix could you
imagine the weight Matrix
that which data layer has more weight in
the decision
and each each parameter
I mean we were doing farming for for
centuries
right but we don't have this
quantitative assessment of how it
impacts our decision making and that's
I've given some Keynotes on farming with
data but there are a lot of questions we
don't know there's a lot of graduate
students here this is phds written right
here what we we don't know what data not
to collect because it doesn't matter so
we're going out and collecting whatever
we can lay our hands on okay or whatever
the graduate student agrees to collect
right
um what kind of Biometrics or
statistical Computing would be needed to
understand relationship within and
across these spatial temporal data set
we don't know that
uh what's a waiter sign and the road
role right and how do we account for
seasonal analysis gonna happen every
year
okay how do we ensure this is
reproducible and reliable and honestly
and this is this is the proposal we
wrote to USDA and the title of the
proposal is artificial intelligence for
sustainability of Agriculture my role is
water uh water and nutrients and then
there are other groups that are looking
at salinity and Pest Management and
diseases uh it's a SAS grant that we
have in motion right now uh and so I I
my this list is very long
what we don't know
okay so we have graduate students who
are working on it I can Envision that
someday will get to a point that will
have in-situ non-destructive rapid
reliable inexpensive sensor Network that
will be collecting data layers that will
be feeding it along with other data sets
Okay and then we'll employ machine
learning and AI will keep the complexity
to ourselves okay and it will be
automated somehow but the decision power
will still be in the hand of the farmer
hey I don't like this decision I I want
to put 20 pounds more no matter what
you're you're telling me I'm gonna put
20 pounds more and that's I think could
be part of the solution I'm not saying
this is the only solution that by 2050
we can reduce our inputs nitrogen and
Water by 50 percent
I'll welcome any questions thank you
yes sir so you mentioned that this
approach requires machine learning and
artificial intelligence
um but I was noticing in your
illustrations especially in the first
slide there's no human beings in these
in these systems so I wonder if you
could talk about what the role of human
intelligence and human Farmers is in
this Republic in this Paradigm so the
question for those who are online the
question is that
um you're talking about a lot of ML and
AI I did not see much human human
intelligence and human intervention you
cannot eliminate human
well
because I sure hope that we are not
requiring all those data layers to be
captured
at some point in time we'll figure it
out that I don't need to go out and
measure soil moisture distribution at 30
minute frequency just because weather
data is recorded or 30 seconds whether
data is recorded that way that I have to
record soil moisture that frequency I
don't know that we would like to you
know and this is where the element of
human intelligence come into play okay
and as I said in the previous slide that
we're not eliminating farmers
so farmer will have the final
decision-making process okay and that
most likely will be happening on their
smartphone or iPad or whatever interface
that we'll be working with we don't want
to overwhelm farmer or for that reason
practitioner uh in the decision-making
process we want to keep that simple keep
the complexity to this group right here
but uh I mean think about many of the
technologies that have been successful
and have been picked up
were intentionally kept simple built on
a very robust complex systems
so we are never eliminating human
intelligence
yeah not in our life fans at least I
know there's an AI chat GPT and so so
many other things out there
yeah good question though
it's my question my question is how are
you going to integrate this I mean you
already have sensors out there called
plants so at what point are you going to
be integrating plant information into
you know they're they're doing already
the integration for you
what's the link there so you're exactly
right uh question is how are you
integrating plants so our group is
taking surrogate measures from crop and
plant responses there are other groups
like mine that are working on implanter
sensors
where they're you know you're using
stickers to stick the sensors to the
leaves uh zapping in electrodes to
measure the sap content continuously
there are several AI Institute that have
been funded through NSF 20 million
dollar grant that are developing those
implant a sensor for uh do exactly what
we are doing here our Focus has always
been on nitrogen water so that we're
going to have to move away from actually
putting things in plants and basically
using animals that remote sensing but in
a sense sort of the because you can't
just keep putting sensors out there and
you need to be able to have mobile maybe
that'll happen I don't know maybe is the
combination of things that will happen I
do not know right now we're just trying
and NASA in 2000 in the year 2000 they
had an implant a sensor by the way I was
looking at the NASA Innovation uh news
report they tested that and they were
measuring the turgor pressure of the
plant and they programmed it to a cell
phone that every time the turgor
pressure was dropping you get a text
message hey water me
right so I mean there are some simpler
technologies that are available it's
just right now it's picking it up and it
will involve a lot of frugal innovation
because if you're trying to do it at
high spatial densities
uh you know even large Farmers can't
afford it I'd like to see where the
instrumentation gets tied into plant
performance so you've got all this
information about souls or climate and
things like that but what is that
implication for plant performance and I
don't want you to carry this impression
there is
equal or larger body of work is being
done with plant s sensors yeah if I did
not cover that today so
all right so foreign
uh I would like to uh see what's your
Envision on a big data management and
regulation policies there's so much data
has been you know going on creating
how will it look like the access to
these big data to the stakeholders
practitioners public general public
right the question has to do with the
big data and the security and the
ownership and how does that look like
that that conversation is happening
Nationwide right now we don't have a
resolution on that or consensus on that
at right now so farmer still owns the
data because there are so many private
companies that are collecting huge
amount of data the the raw data is still
owned by the data and the fine print
says that the derivative in my
understanding is that the derivative
could be used for other purposes but not
the direct data set
just last week no this week Monday we
visited a farmer who manages 43 000
acres in Colby
and and he has been collecting data for
last 20 years and he was he was one of
the rare Farmers he was very open to
giving the data set if we can translate
that into meaningful decisions I've not
found a lot of farmers like that and and
it goes into a cloud you know he's he
was a John Deere customer and um of
course the derivatives are being derived
so that continuous Improvement whether
it's machine performance or labor
working in the field or not or pivot is
is clogged or you know whatever that
might be but we don't have a solution on
the ownership if that's what you're
getting at right now yeah
all righty thank you very much Raj so
another round thank you
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu